hydrosa bonjour vous êtes architecte
urbaniste vous avez été l'architecte du
centre-ville de 50 ans en Yvelines et
vous publiez aux éditions de l'Harmattan
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le
centre-ville 1973 2003 une épopée
urbaine un livre qui a évidemment deux
objectifs le premier bah c'est de
marquer les souvenirs que vous avez les
souvenirs de ceux qui ont participé à la
construction de cette ville nouvelle et
puis pour les nouveaux habitants de
Saint-Quentin
comment s'est construite cette ville
c'est ça les deux objectifs vous pouvez
tout à fait ce sont mes deux objectifs
parce que je voulais acter tout un passé
que l'oralité la transmission orale a
tendance à déformer donc par l'écrit je
sais que c'est écrit sera aux archives
sera dans les bibliothèques etc donc ce
sont ces ma mémoire comme je dis je ne
confisque pas la mémoire des autres je
dis la vérité est pluriel donc d'autres
peuvent écrire voilà c'est le premier
objectif et le deuxième c'est que les
habitants puissent éventuellement avoir
une connaissance de cette vie nouvelle
particulière donc quand il n'était pas
là alors je dois ajouter quand même que
ce livre je l'ai écrit sur une
injonction en clair de Paul de l'ouvrier
qui a un soir ici au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin a dit à ma femme madame
drossa vous devrez veiller à ce que
votre mari écrit l'histoire du centre de
Saint-Quentin il faut dire un mot de
peut-être parce que tout le monde ne le
connaît pas de qui est paul de Louvrier
qui a été au fond le maître d'oeuvre à
la fois de la du découvrage de la région
parisienne d'alcool la commune
aujourd'hui et puis Devil nouvelle voilà
alors Paul de l'ouvrier faites à
travailler
sous la demande du général de Gaulle en
1964 quand la région parisienne
explosait et de Gaulle a demandé à de
l'ouvrier qu'il a nommé en clair super
préfet je dirais de la phrase mythique
c'est mettez-moi un peu d'ordre dans
tout ce bordel voilà donc Paul de
l'ouvrier
vous devriez donc à créer un certain à
créer plus que des choses urbaines je
dirais il a réorganisé
administrativement la région parisienne
il a créé les organismes d'études dont
il y a eu RP c'est à dire l'Institut
d'aménagement et d'urbanisme de la
région parisienne et puis l'agence
foncière pour les acquisitions des
soldes donc il a organisé les nouveaux
départements voilà et là c'est lui qui a
initié ces villes c'est intéressant que
vous parliez de Paul de l'ouvrier parce
que l'image de Paul d'ouvrier c'est
grand serviteur de l'État tout à fait en
réalité tout ce qu'on voit ici
n'aurait pas été possible sans d'abord
le fait du prince ou la volonté de
l'État sans l'avendeur sans la volonté
de l'État pardon il n'y aurait pas eu
ces nouvelles et aujourd'hui bon je ne
veux pas dénigrer le présent soyons
clairs mais
le prolon les prolongement urbanistiques
par exemple vers le plateau de Saclay on
reparle bien sûr donc là faut que ça te
plaît etc ne se font pas dans les mêmes
conditions d'établissement public
c'est-à-dire d'intervention forte de
l'État
moi je crois assez que l'État et le
meilleur vecteur pour des pour des
projets urbanistiques de grande ampleur
mais c'est une volonté assez
exceptionnelle elle sait exceptionnelle
aussi pour pour quelqu'un comme vous je
suppose parce que vous arrivez ici jeune
architecte et on vous dit voilà 33 ans
alors c'était une des caractéristiques
des équipes d'établissements publics il
y a d'ailleurs été souvent relevé c'est
que ces équipes étaient constituées de
gens extrêmement jeunes donc on était là
jeune architecte 33 ans et on avait en
charge des projets absolument
monumentaux mon directeur général
j'étais engagé par Serge Goldberg le
premier directeur de la bonne nouvelle
donc qui était aussi un grand un grand
commis de l'État mais mon deuxième
directeur pierre Linden avec qui j'ai
fait l'essentiel de ceci avait 38 ans
quand on a monté tous les grands projets
du cœur de ville ici disons et ça a été
une aventure absolument sans sans
commune mesure elle a justement quand on
a 33 ans comme ça qu'on arrive qu'on a
cette responsabilité là qui est quand
même énorme quel est quels sont les
premiers problèmes pour les premières
questions qu'on se pose
comment dire moi je suis arrivé ici
quand Goldberg m'a confié la ZAC centre
la saxante il faut voir c'est 500
hectares et 2 millions et demi de mètres
carrés de plancher construits
de bureau de
150.130m2 de commerce 350 000
équipements c'est énorme mais quand il
m'a confié cette affaire il y avait déjà
des quartiers qui avaient commencé les
prêts et le pas du lac suivant une forme
d'urbanisme
que moi j'appelle la dernière comment
dirais la dernière manifestation des
grands ensembles dans la trame urbaine
par le l'opération les opérations encore
demain et il n'y avait pas non plus de
définition de l'espace public pour moi
l'urbanisme c'est d'abord
pour moi l'urbanisme c'est le dessin de
l'espace public et dans ce dessin
d'espace public on définit les parcelles
de construction qui viennent
effectivement border ces espaces aux
échelles nécessaires en fonction des etc
des tailles et je suis reparti donc de
ces concepts qui étaient mes concepts et
j'ai le premier quartier que j'ai étudié
a été le quartier des garennes où je
vais introduit la notion de boulevard la
notion de rue la notion de place avec
l'immobilier à l'échelle durée
correspondante pour les encadrer
nous avions édicté notre credo en
matière d'urbanisme c'était notamment la
liaison entre la base de loisirs et la
vallée de la bière puisqu'on est un
cheval sur les deux il fallait rétablir
ça on avait établi notre credo pas
d'urbanisme de dalle mise en valeur des
équipements publics un urbanisme d'une
autre etc etc et on a monté un appel
d'idée c'est à dire un concours auprès
de neuf équipes d'architectes
après ces études on a choisi un projet
on a fait une première tranche
opérationnelle on a eu les promoteurs
pour le faire et sont arrivés les
élections présidentielles et
législatives de 1981 qui ont porté la
gauche au pouvoir c'est à dire François
Mitterrand et la gauche à l'Assemblée et
du coup les élus locaux ici au sein du
scan nous ont imposé d'abandonner notre
projet ce projet que l'on menait je
dirais plus en connivence au bon sens du
terme avec Nicolas Abou ils ont imposé
l'arrêt ils ont voulu remonter à un
autre concours avec d'autres architectes
ils avaient choisi ça a tourné au fiasco
en clair
Nicolas Abou au moment de choisir à
voter pour son architecte on classe
celui de l'Opéra
les socialiste les socialistes pour le
leur et les communistes pour le leur
c'est devenu politique c'est ce qui
s'appelle ce qui est une balle dans le
pied et au bout du compte ils ont
demandé à l'EPA de reprendre le projet
et c'est nous qui avons dessiné le
dernier plan celui qui s'est construit
du cœur de 50 ans en Yvelines alors là
on est on parlez d’équipe d'architectes
vous dites que ça c'est le terme de
Voltaire de 50 ans vous dites c'est le
chef-d'œuvre
dû à un grand architecte c'est vrai que
vous avez aussi appel à des grands
architectes
est-ce que vous motorisez un tout petit
avance de parler de l'architecture l'une
des caractéristiques de l'hypercentre de
50 ans du cœur de ville c'est
l'intrication plus que l’imbrication
c'est l'intrication entre la forme
urbaine et la forme du de
l'organisation commerciale d'accord
toutes les villes nouvelles ont
construit un centre commercial fermé
comme une boîte et avec un élément de
ville autour ici on n'a pas voulu ça on
a dit le commerce doit entièrement
irriguer la ville et comme il fallait en
plus intégrer un hypermarché 20 000
mètres carrés on n'a pas on a trouvé ce
moyen absolument inédit c'est d'enterrer
ce supermarché pour passer sous l'avenue
du centre et pour se connecter à des
rues piétonnes alors pour revenir alors
aux archives c'est vrai que voilà il y a
eu des grands architectes qui sont
comment vous avez fait appel à eux
c'était des concours c'était toujours
par concours façon pour le grand les
équipements publics c'est les élus sont
maître d'ouvrage des équipements et le
pH était maître d'ouvrage de léguer ça a
toujours été l'émission de l'Opéra et
donc on proposait on a proposé ces deux
pa qui proposaient des architectes de
grand renom pour effectivement avoir
cette qualité architecturale c'est alors
on doit notamment au début c'est je
dirais c'est à Pierre Linden par exemple
d'avoir eu recours à eux et on doit
beaucoup à Jean-Paul Alduy qui était mon
troisième directeur général c'est ça
d'avoir notamment fait appel à Dominique
Perrault pour les immeubles les lumières
à
faire les non échappent pour la
bibliothèque universitaire qui est
magnifique voilà là c'est une volonté de
trouver une autre architecture si très
signifiante alors
avec le recul aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a des choses
vous êtes fiers évidemment
et dans l'ensemble parce que au fond
quand on regarde vraiment les mêmes
nouvelles Saint-Quentin est un exemple
de réussite tout ne sont pas non alors
il est vrai que dans le milieu des
années 90 fin des années 90 à un
chercheur en urbanisme de l'Université
de l'école d'architecture de Paris
Belleville elle fait une grande étude
sur l'ensemble des villes nouvelles et
il avait effectivement c'était il avait
dit que 50 ans en Yvelines cet état qui
la réputation de la plus réussie de vie
nouvelle le centre de Saint-Quentin
c'était à qui la réputation donc il dit
pas que ça allait mais bon ça ressemble
à ça ressemble à la lettre est-ce qu'il
y a quand même une chose comme ça qui
qui constitue comme un regret pour vous
c'est pas un regret c'est une
interrogation je veux dire par là que
l'ensemble du centre je parle du centre
je parle pas des autres quartiers je
connais bien l'histoire mais ce serait
trop compliqué l'ensemble du centre
c'est ça que de 500 hectares et
construit sur des grands axes vierges
comme cette avenue du centre comme les
avenues de pénétration et de sortie
comme les grands mailles vierges sont
des mailles droits comme le parc qui
pénètre etc tout ça ce sont de grandes
structures qui sont à l'échelle de cette
de cette urbanisme et donc ce sont des
traces pour l'avenir il y aura pas de
Haussmann pour recouper donc c'est des
traces pour l'avenir par contre je
m'interroge un peu sur l'échelle de la
rue piétonne
c'est un truc piétonne est très aimable
on y est bien c'est confortable c'est
c'est une architecture très à même c'est
tout ce qu'on voudra mais la question au
fond c'est est-ce que c'est la bonne
échelle pour un centre d'une ville aussi
importante que 50 ans et je prends pour
exemple les grandes piétonnes du monde
si on prend la rue de la République à
Lyon la rue de nantin à Shanghai alors
on pourrait les multiplier les exemples
sont généralement beaucoup plus font
plus de personnalité que ça et là on
s'est trouvé confronté comme je dis bien
qu'ayant une forme de ville on avait
encore des contraintes de centre
commercial et là il y a un peu ambiguïté
mais ça oui aussi c'était moi aussi
d'une époque c'est tout à fait alors
quand même une grande fierté c'est l'art
public quand même et la République quoi
plusieurs il y a leur public il y a le
nombre de lieux culturels enfin bref qui
sont aussi des choses parce que il y
avait il y a eu quand même cette
utopie formidable de dire on va créer
une ville quoi oui ah oui oui
qui est maintenant comment dirais-je
entre guillemets incarné dans le béton
enfin alors j'ai employé ce mot
excusez-moi tout le monde va sauter
dessus en disant il y a trop de béton il
y a trop de béton c'est l'horreur ça
c'est l'horreur alors qu'il y a des
arbres on ne sait plus où il y en a
tellement on sait pour vous parfois on
ne voit plus la ville pour Hitler non
non donc c'est une note une utopie de
venir réalité
merci beaucoup je rappelle le titre de
votre ville 50 ans en Yvelines le
centre-ville 1973 2003 c'est aux
éditions l'Harmattan et vous serez le 5
octobre entre 16 et 18h à la librairie
du pavé du canal pour signer ce livre et
puis parler évidemment à ceux qui
avouent
pour ceux qui veulent merci infiniment
merci au revoir